>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> Our final talk before the
break is from Stephen Robertson
who is Director of the Roy
Rosenzweig Center for History
and New Media and Professor History
at the George Mason University.
He will tell a story
about Digital Harlem,
a project that won the American
Historical Association's Roy
Rosenzweig Prize for
Innovation in Digital History
and the ABC CLIO Online
History Award
of the American Library
Association in 2010.
You're on, Stephen.
>> Stephen Robertson: Good morning.
[ Applause ]
Applause [inaudible].
I just want to start with a quick
shout out to the wonderful team
of people here at the
Library of Congress
who have brought us all here
today, and a fascinating group
of people they've brought.
I'm going to go back to maps which
it shows you a lot at the beginning
to talk about data in place.
Historical sources are full of
data about places and locations.
The spatial data is not very
intelligible in textual form,
and even when extracted and
organized in tabular form,
it really doesn't tell us a lot.
It's hard to discern the
story that it has to tell us.
Now, mapping has been around for a
long time as a tool for making sense
of the spatial data, but it's
only really with the advent
of web mapping that
it's become accessible
to a wider range of people.
You used to have to go find the
GIS person in your university
to make you a map for a project,
and that was going to be the one map
that you did if you had
the months to do that.
The web has fundamentally
transformed that, and the project
that I'm here to talk
about today owes its form
to the launch of Google
Maps in 2005.
Shane White put together
a team of four historians,
University of Sydney, of
which I was the junior member,
to do a study of everyday life
in New York City's Harlem
neighborhood in the 1920s.
Our key sources for this
to get beyond the political
and artistic elite
that dominate accounts
of Harlem was New York City's
two black newspapers, The Age
and the Amsterdam News
and the records
of the Manhattan District Attorney.
Now, I was in that project because
I'd used those legal records
in my dissertation, and I knew from
the dissertation that they were full
of information about where things
happened that I'd found no way
to use and analyze when
I did the dissertation.
So, what I suggested
as my contribution
to this larger project was
an effort to map our sources.
Now, when we got funding for the
project in 2004, the technology
for doing that was our GIS, and
I went away to find collaborators
at the University of Sydney,
our experts in art GIS,
to make that happen.
And, at Sydney at that time,
it was the archeological
computing laboratory.
However, the problem
with art GIS in 2004 was
that it was not possible
to use it on the web.
It wouldn't run on our
beloved Macintosh computers,
and it simply was, as it still
is, far too hard to master
and far too complex
to make it worth using
to analyze the qualitative
data that we had.
So, and, thankfully, with the launch
of Google Maps in 2005 and thanks
to Damian Evans, one of our team who
created a hack between our database
and Google Maps, we launched
Digital Harlem in 2009
as a web based form of mapping.
As with any large digital project,
there's a whole team
of people behind that.
And, before I say anything
more, I want to acknowledge all
of those people in addition to
the ones I've already named,
a team of historians,
graduate research assistants,
technologists of various kinds,
and almost a million dollars
of Australian government money
which always amuses people.
But, the Australian government,
at least in the early 2000s,
was interested in funding
innovative scholarship even
about black neighborhoods
thousands of miles away.
Now, Digital Harlem was one
of the first historical
we mapping projects,
and one of the first digital
history projects to shift
from what the Valley of the Shadow
was really interested in doing,
digitizing material, creating online
collections towards visualizing
those sources.
Now better technologies now
exist for web mapping projects.
Nevertheless, Digital Harlem remains
a useful starting point for thinking
about mapping as a means of
making sources more accessible,
more visual, and more useful.
The contrast here is
research with access
and sources through a database.
I think Michell Whitelaw's
formulation which I'm sure many
of you are familiar
with, captures this best.
Search is ungenerous.
Demanding a query and returning
only the terms you enter.
Withholding information about the
structure and materials available
and filtering out any
alternative hypotheses.
Visualizations, by contrast, are
generous, rich, browsable interfaces
that reveal the scale and
complexity of the data behind them
and provide a context, a context
that enriches the exploration
and analysis of that data.
So, Digital Harlem is not an
interface to a collection of forces.
Thanks to copyright, licensing, and
restrictions imposed by archives,
it's not possible for us, even if
we'd wanted to, which we didn't,
to offer access to the sources
on which the site draws.
But, those restrictions do not
prevent the creation of data
from those sources which is
what Digital Harlem contains,
information about events, an
ill-fated tennis tournament
in this case, about people, and to
a much lesser extent, about, sorry,
much lesser extent about people.
A lot about places.
It's worth noting that those of
us who work on the 20th century
and beyond encounter
this problem with access
to sources far more
often than our colleagues
who work in earlier periods.
We need to be talking more about the
way in which restrictions on access
to sources shape the kind of
digital projects we can do
on the 20th century and how creating
data is a way of getting access
to material that's
otherwise under copyright.
To create data, however, requires
a different engagement with sources
than humanity scholars
typically have.
Whereas, to use Miriam
Posner's words,
we usually immerse
ourselves in our sources.
Dive in. Understand
them from within.
To create data is to
extract information.
And, features from sources requiring
a decomposition of a subject
or object into attributes
and variables.
If you're now increasing range
of computational tools to do
that extraction for you,
the data that we gathered
for Digital Harlem was done by hand.
And, because of the problems of
access to digitized newspapers
and the limits of ACR,
it's still a process
that needs to be done by hand.
So, myself and the team of research
assistants who appear briefly
on the screen recorded
details of every location
and every event associated with
the location in those legal records
that I was talking about.
And, in the Harlem's
two black newspapers.
And, crucially, in a way that Ed was
alluding to, not just information
from the news stories,
but information
from every section
of the newspapers.
The fraternal reports, the
church records, the sports pages.
There's far more information and
far more spatial data in newspapers
than we're used to thinking about
when we roll the microfilm through
and looked for the news
stories that were part of that.
We organized that information
into a data model,
entered it into a database, and
geocoded it so that could be mapped.
Now, the metaphor that we commonly
use to describe that process,
mining, sits awkwardly with humanity
scholars concerned with development
of empathy with an appreciation of
the position of the person or group
or the qualities of an object.
It sets up a sense of creating
data as somehow dehumanizing.
Mapping data can somehow
mitigate that consequence,
can align with an orientation
towards [inaudible] data,
one element of which is articulated
by [inaudible] as an appreciation
of context, interdependence,
and vulnerability.
Maps as a visualization express this
relationship of parts one to another
and to many to a greater whole.
Mapping data, mapped data is
seen at its geographical context,
and [inaudible] Digital Harlem by
the use of a historical map player.
A Bromley Real Estate atlas which
shares a lot of the information
and qualities of the [inaudible]
and Sanborn fire insurance maps.
It provides building footprints,
information on the height
of those buildings, the
material they're made out of,
whether they have shops
or stores in them.
What it does most dramatically in
terms of the maps that we're used
to looking at in historical
scholarship is filled
in the spaces on a street map.
And, in that way, the
space literally divides,
helps to subdivide and divide
Harlem into multiple smaller places
and to give some indication
of how those places interact.
And, if you know anything about
the history of Harlem in the 1920s,
I chose this flock because on the
corner is renaissance ballroom
and casino, the sight of a lot
of dances and entertainment
and basketball games next
to the establishment
Abyssinian Baptist Church,
one of the main line middle class
moral racial [inaudible] of Harlem.
And, the hall to the right of
that was the former headquarters
of Marcus Garvey's
black nationalist UNIA.
A very interesting gathering of
people walking down those blocks
in a way that we don't appreciate
without this kind of level of data.
One of the very exciting things
going on right here at the Library
of Congress is the digitization
of Sanborn fire insurance maps.
We're just going to put
these incredibly rich sources
into people's hand, make them freely
accessible, transform the kind
of historical mapping
projects we can do
by adding this incredibly
rich layer of data
about what the place is like.
Layer the different data,
and hence large quantities
of data can be combined on a
single map, providing an image
of the complexity of the past.
And, I'm going to come back to
this really complex looking map.
You can examine maps of sources at
different scales, make comparisons,
discover relationships by
visually detecting spatial patents
that remain hidden in those texts
and tables that we started with.
Now, mapping data has become
an increasingly common form
of interface for a lot
of digital collections.
But, too often, those projects
map only a single collection
of material.
That approach takes really only a
small part of the power of mapping.
Geographic location provides
a means to integrate material
from a wide range of
disparate sources.
So, what's important about assigning
a geographic reference to data,
as Karen Kemp puts it, then
becomes possible to compare
that characteristic of the
phenomenon, etc. with others
that exist or have existed
in the same geographic space.
What were previously unrelated facts
become integrated and correlated.
The power of maps to bring
disparate things together is
where we really need to be
going with them as a technology.
Used in this way, the geospatial web
can help us capture the confluence
of multiple rhythms that [inaudible]
argues make up everyday life.
So, this is one of my go
to examples for talking
about Harlem in the 1920s.
It's a map of nightlife
during prohibition using data
from newspapers, undercover
investigations, legal records.
It shows the venues which drew
crowds to Harlem, the night clubs,
the speakeasys, and the venues
that black residents opened
in their apartments,
known as buffet flats,
catering exclusively to blacks.
The map highlights the different
geographies of those venues and,
in particular, the clustering
of buffet flats in sections away
from the other venues, away from
whites, and drew our attention
to how blacks developed spaces
apart from whites as they flocked
to Harlem's night life in the 1920s.
Now, while this map captures some
of how prohibition shaped night life
and leisure in Harlem,
it's only a partial map
of the commercialized leisure
available in the neighborhood.
Digital Harlem lets you create
the context by adding dance halls,
theaters, pool rooms, the halls
that hosted basketball games
and boxing bouts, and
then you can add
to those commercial
venues [inaudible]
to understand night
life, all of the places
where noncommercial leisure took
place in Harlem in this period.
Meetings of church
groups, fraternal lodges,
community organizations,
and social clubs.
You end up with this
incredibly complex map.
Social clubs.
Incredibly complex map
which highlights fundamentally
just how a small segment of leisure
and night life in Harlem actually
appears in discussions focused
on prohibition which defines the way
that we understand what
Harlem was like in the 1920s.
In regards to mapping
events rather than places,
this is one of the first maps
we created, arrests for numbers
in 1925, which gave our
research a new focus.
It shows in the first instance
the sheer pervasiveness
of numbers gambling which is
a picture that a multitude
of sources reinforced in Harlem,
and it's one reason why Shane White,
Steven Garton, and Graham
White, and I wrote a book
about the wide ranging economic and
cultural role of numbers gambling
in Harlem as one of the
outcomes of our collaboration.
Zooming in to that map highlights
how placing bets was woven
into everyday life.
Arrests occurred on street corners
as residents get on their way
to work, and the businesses
lining the avenues
as they went shopping
and ran errands.
And, in their homes,
on the cross streets
as numbers runners went door
to door collecting bets.
Our original concept for Digital
Harlem also included mapping
individual lives, but assembling
enough data to reveal more
than a single moment
of an individual's life
proved beyond our resources.
However, we did generate maps
for a handful of people based
on information on their
residence, work, and leisure
and probation and parole records.
Those maps make visible the
extent to which the lives
of Harlem's residents were not
bounded by the neighborhood,
made clear that the census data that
we commonly rely on to determine
where people lived ultimately
only tells us where they slept.
So, for example, during the five
years that Morgan Thompson was
on probation, his work as a laborer
took him not only outside Manhattan
but to the Bronx, Queens,
and Brooklyn.
We've used lines linking residents
with the workplaces and other places
that people frequented
while [inaudible]
to suggest their movement
through the city.
The geography of work was
often different for women.
Annie Dillard, like the majority
of Harlem women in the workforce,
found paid employment as a
domestic servant in homes
on the upper west side,
hotels in midtown,
and in a laundry in lower Manhattan.
The newest version of Digital
Harlem adds a timeline to this
to understand how these
lives evolved.
Two strikingly different
geographies,
two strikingly different
reminders that living
in a city is not living
in the neighborhood.
It's moving across the city in a way
that we don't often place African
Americans in places like New York.
Now, for all the maps that
we feature on the site
and that we discuss in our
scholarship, much of the usefulness
and impact of Digital Harlem
comes from how it allows users
to make their own maps, to visualize
the data that interests them rather
than being constrained to what
interests the site's creators.
That capacity highlights that
these maps are exploratory,
not illustrative, that
they raise questions rather
than answering them.
But, the site itself, unfortunately,
offers limited help in making sense
of a map and the data it visualizes.
That design is in keeping with the
original conception of the site
which was as a research
tool for those
of us collaborating on
the original project.
When we decided to share the
site, we added some material
about the places and
events featured on the site
and on the individuals
whose lives can be mapped.
And, we created a blog that
linked to the site with posts
about additional maps of places and
events such as traffic accidents
in this example that
incorporate additional material
like photographs.
Unfortunately, those after the
fact efforts can only go so far.
Creating a real context
for understanding the data
in Digital Harlem is a
project in its own right
that will require a wholesale
redesign of the site,
and it's one of the things that we
need to think about the difference
because producing sites that
are research tools for people
who understand the data at some
level and sites that are shared
and are going to be used by people
who don't bring the researcher's
understanding to the site.
Now, an emerging offer, option
for making data more accessible
and useful is to use what's
in Digital Harlem as the basis
for a spatial narrative
rather than simply a map.
I'm currently exploring
that approach for a project
on the 1935 Harlem Riot for which
we're creating another version
of Digital Harlem based
on that single year.
By the 1930s, there's a much greater
wealth of information about life
in Harlem than there
is in the 1920s.
Now, a platform like the widely
used story map [inaudible]
which creates a linear single path
through a map cannot effectively
tell the story of a complex event
like the riot in which multiple
things happened at any given time.
Neither, for that matter,
can following the timeline
on Digital Harlem let you understand
what is going on in the riot.
Neatline, a mapping plugging for
[inaudible] which Ed was talking
about earlier, gives some scope
for more complex storytelling,
and I've created a prototype
narrative of the riot just
to think about, there we go, just
to think about what's possible.
What I really like about Neatline
is that the timeline slider
at the bottom of that image provides
a means of navigating the exhibit.
Dragging it not only changes the
points that appear on the map.
It also alters the way
points visible on the right.
While points display information
on particular events, way points,
way points can be used
for broader arguments
which can be grouped together
rather than being tied
to a single point on the timeline.
What that means is that it
gives you some flexibility
in how a narrative is reared.
You can roll over each way
point in a group or explore them
in a sequence, or out of sequence.
Each way point can be associated
with a zoom level on
a specific location.
Clicking on a series of way points
can, thus, move you around a map.
And, you can annotate those way
points, attach them to polygons
and lines as I have in this
prototype to draw attention
to the analysis of space in my
understanding of what's going
on in the riot, to movement,
direction, proximity,
connection, and patterns.
Used in that way, annotations
shift some of the argument
into visual form, and that's
ultimately where I think we're going
with the kinds of visualizations
we've been making in maps,
that the future direction in
visualizing data using maps
that this prototype points to
is the capacity more extensively
and dynamically integrate
maps in narratives.
To visually combine data
and interpretation while retaining
the orientation towards putting data
in context, which, to me,
is the most powerful thing
that mapping lets us do.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.